Hillsdale was a very good place to be in
late 50s
my brother attended Hillsdale and was a
good athlete there the previous few
years and he knew all the coaches and I
think he put a good word in for me to
get a scholarship so I had moved up
there in August for early football
practice and the rest is history
it probably impressed the coaches in the
four years I was there I never missed
the practice and sometimes that's not
easy to do especially in football I
think I got on this good side of Coach
waters and the other coaches because I
was willing to sacrifice and no matter
what I was gonna make practice and I
never missed a game and in my senior
year we went to the mineral bowl in Cape
Girardeau Missouri we wound up winning
which is I think the only bowl game that
Hillsdale College ever won and I'm proud
of the fact that I was on that team I
wasn't the best student in the world but
I was able to do a decent job my first
two years I was a a seed B student my
last two years and I credit my wife now
Peggy because I become a be a student
with her prodding and and making sure
that I kept the right things in order
which was academics obviously I met her
at kindergarten they're here at new
Troy's oh it's been quite a relationship
that we've had
and knowing her since she was 4 years
old in kindergarten I decided to the
closest thing I could get staying in
athletics was to go into coaching I went
into the high school ranks and I coached
a total of 48 years the last 10 being an
assistant to my son who was at Lake
Michigan College so a majority of my
time the 38 years was at high school and
most of those were at River Valley high
school I was very fortunate to have
great teams great players and players
who sacrifice for the good of the team
and as a result I was a beneficiary of
many good experiences we were over the
years with very successful eight or nine
districts and five or six regionals we
went to the Final Four four times that
first year in 1979 we won the
championship going to the Final Four
meant the first three years we played at
Chrysler arena and believe me that was a
thrill from a little little country boy
here in Sawyer Michigan I have
tremendous support from my family my
four sons our daughter-in-laws my
grandkids unbelievable support and when
the times get tough their support even
grows believe me Peggy and I appreciate
that a great deal
[Music]
you
[Music]